[Music]
it takes a lot of things to become an
esports
superstar unmistakable qualities like
natural talent it's all down to bolo the
man the myth the legend can he possibly
do it he has the hot mark bolo you have
to be able to get the last kill can he
do what he does a restless dedication
that borders on obsession
yeah you got it just off the block but
you didn't have the meter until the
third is the chip damage for the win
tokido 2-0 and of course you can't earn
street cred without silverware
[Applause]
but as much as we've invested our time
into watching the stories of these
gaming celebrities unfold the truth is
we basically know nothing about them
sure we can watch them on stream and
catch glimpses of their personal lives
but what if we did more what if we could
tear down the stages and soundproof
booths and really spend time with our
heroes now for most of us fanboys that
thought is
tragically
just a pipe dream
but there is one guy who's been able to
turn it
into a reality i'm talking of course
about tyler tyler1 steinkamp the juiced
up but occasionally misunderstood league
of legends die hard who's a stature in
the scene
is
simply
gigantic hey talk some [ __ ] now hey
awesome
who's talking to the champ ain't nobody
prior to his self-proclaimed reformation
tyler1 was the flagship toxic [ __ ]
streamer for riot's much beloved moba he
was famous for running it down mid and
generally just throwing tantrums and
games when he didn't get his way
bro that [ __ ] straight down
there we go baby it's been a long time
after serving a two-year ban for
behavior like that tyler was given a
second chance at redemption in 2018
which for the most part he achieved even
still tyler1 wasn't exactly the kind of
guy you'd want associated with your
esports scene his name being mentioned
in the same breath as any of the game's
biggest stars was a laughable thought
and yet in the past couple of years this
eardrum destroying manlet has somehow
developed an unlikely friendship with
lee faker sang-hyuk the korean god of
league of legends whose awkward
innocence is but a deceptive mask that
conceals a merciless genius the veto
faker may be in trouble your death mark
tries to clean it up for ryu oh look at
the class look at the moves thank her
what was that
so
how is it that a guy who was once called
the most toxic person in league
somehow became best friends with the
unkillable demon king what makes them
the perfect odd couple and what exactly
does faker get out of their strange
partnership alright here is one
let's call it a day i gotta go
[Music]
all right folks before we dive into what
is undoubtedly the weirdest bromance in
all of esports i'm gonna ask that you
like the video
run it down mid to the sub button and
spank on notifications
jesus
these get worse every week
all right so you probably know tyler1 as
league of legends most iconic
rage-a-holic he's been streaming the
game for years and his commitments to
that grind has turned him into its
biggest streamer yes he literally gets
more views than riot but when you look
beyond his domination of metrics on
twitch the truth is
tyler1 is just your average league of
legends superfan he shares his
sophisticated takes on riot's perfectly
balanced meta changes i'm so sick of
this [ __ ] company
the trash
fix the guy
it sucks playing the [ __ ]
and he has a totally normal appreciation
of his favorite champions who this
[ __ ] jawline
look at that
look at that power in that jawline look
at that beautiful luscious hair look at
the this delt these deltoids right here
got a little bit of vascularity coming
right here
i eat you like a snack now even though
league has historically made tyler1 lose
his [ __ ] harder than a g fueled 12
12-year-old playing call of duty
the truth is
he loves it and that infatuation has
grown beyond just playing the game in
fact he's become pretty invested in its
esports scene hello everybody i am live
here at the tyler1 dome the atmosphere
in here and i have never seen anything
like this before in my life now when it
comes to league teams there's only one
for tyler1 and that's t1 and no it's not
just because they share initials it's
because team one is kind of a big deal
they are without a doubt the most
legendary and internationally successful
league of legends org of all time having
won three worlds titles and countless
other domestic championships since
entering the scene in 2012 and at the
heart of t1's unmatched trophy hall is
their star player
faker
dang we're gonna come in here comes your
[Applause]
their
initiation
will find them all and skt with a hell
of a response will take down four under
turrets wolf coming in level six they
get the flash from knocking a faker
comes in he's got the old he's got the
kill
beautiful beautiful game from skt
dodged that petrified gaze
so beautifully i almost couldn't see it
the play towards top side they do see
faker and the cocoon's not gonna land
though so can they get anything else the
flash chase it's steph onto his face
looking for a little bit more and he's
not gonna go down faker
with just the ghost gets away with it
now despite being the greatest league of
legends player of all time the last few
years of faker's career have actually
been a bit disappointing since winning
his last worlds in 2016 the unkillable
demon king and t1 have floundered on the
international stage whether that's in
the form of being prematurely eliminated
from major competitions
or failing to qualify for them entirely
for a player with a history of success
as rich as fakers anything less than
victory is going to result in a massive
amount of criticism but as easy as it
might have been for tyler1 to jump off
the faker bandwagon through the bad
times he's proven himself to be one of
his hero's most loyal supporters these
people who are who are [ __ ] talking
faker
calling him
like oh look at
look at shaker dude huh
look at shaker
nice because he's in a high pressure
situation his adrenaline is pumping
and here's the thing
the most
adrenaline you [ __ ] losers have ever
had pumping is when you had to choose
which way to go to class
to avoid the school bully now if you're
an og league fan like tyler1 it's easy
to see past the criticism of the game's
greatest ever player
after all everyone in esports is labeled
washed as soon as results stop going
their way but faker's recent struggles
present a problem of a different sort
now don't get me wrong no korean player
on any korean team has ever become a
household name in the west the same way
that faker has but that's down to his
success on the rift the issue is that if
he isn't regularly lifting trophies
faker doesn't really have that big of a
marketable presence in the west barring
a few memed upon blips from our
perspective his image is that of a stoic
unflappable god sure he occasionally
streams on twitch but unless you
understand korean
good luck following along
now in years past this sort of cultural
disconnect wouldn't actually have been
that big of a problem but since t1
partnered with comcast back in 2019
they've been trying to expand their
esports presence in the west so t1 the
org not the guy was faced with a problem
their most marketable popular player
wasn't shining on the game's biggest
stage and on top of that he came across
as this cold skill-shotting robot to
western fans because of a cultural
divide a characterization that's not
really fair especially if you see how he
behaves for korean audiences
[Music]
but the solution to t1's faker problem
had actually presented itself back at
all stars 2018 when the unkillable demon
king first crossed paths with the
unbannable draven simp you see after
burying the hatchet with riot tyler1 was
brought out as a special guest at the
event and being a vip he finally had the
chance to meet his hero in the flesh
which as he told travis gafford he could
barely contain his excitement over look
listen to me
i swear to god i made him here
sorry i didn't even hurt you i made him
very strong he like he chuckled i i was
like this yeah and he's like but the
best part about their impromptu meaning
is that tyler1 wasn't the only one who
was excited about it
[Music]
at first glance tyler1 and faker don't
seem like they'd be instant friends i
mean
you couldn't think of two more opposite
people the out-of-control rager and the
stoic master the toxic meme lord and the
three-time world champion the king of
league on twitch
and the king of league on lane the
superstar
and the super fan
tyler
in celebration of our recent lck spring
split victory
t1 would like to present you this gift
t1 recognizes t1
we hope you will tune into msi and cheer
us on next month
ps love
tyler1.com wait
don't tell me
wait
no way
and by all rights that should have been
the end of the story
but it wasn't despite their very obvious
differences culturally and just as human
beings t1 realized that faker and tyler1
had a natural dynamic that made them
perfect for each other and so in a bid
to broaden faker's western appeal the
organization brought the two league of
legends juggernauts together over their
mutual love of junk food and
man was it glorious what's your favorite
food i've ever eaten korean chicken i
have not that's good is it yeah maybe we
could get some sometime dude it could be
a date
i'm busy sorry you want to trade no no
please
please trade give me money
how is yours
[Music]
good
hi steve we are basically best friends
now from a content perspective this
pairing is simply gold tyler1's ability
to effortlessly command the spotlight
helps to loosen up the famously rigid
faker meanwhile faker's presence helps
keep tyler1 in check because i mean he's
just happy to be included although
that's not to say that tyler1 isn't
afraid to embarrass himself in front of
faker all right here is one
okay
let's call it a day i gotta go man can
you please do on the left cheek
i even
only one more you ready last one
all right that's a wrap
hug it out you just assaulted me now to
say that the experiment was a success
would be an understatement and off the
back of the positive reception of the
first video t1 followed it up with a
semi-competitive play date for the duo
at a retro arcade are you good at
playing game i'm gonna play in every
single game in the world already i'm not
oh faker okay you're not gonna be humble
to me man oh
this is painful i'm as good as you and
you're as good as me yeah and in league
of legends
[Music]
together the two videos have over 5
million views and you've got to imagine
that covid is the only reason we haven't
gotten more but faker isn't the only one
who benefited from this content union
the videos were so well received by the
community that tyler1 was rewarded with
a streaming contract by t1 paving the
way for more faker tyler1 content hello
tyrone
hey bud how you doing man
hi are you good and you
bad you look pretty good yeah that's
right tyler1 called faker live on stream
and while it's doubtful that they're
gabbing every day these unscripted
interactions go a long way to not only
making their bond feel real but
humanizing them both faker makes tyler1
come off less like a cartoon character
and more like someone you could actually
be friends with whereas tyler1 makes
faker feel like more than some sort of
revered fleshy calculator rock muscle
me
you rook
you look so
big
even though their friendship might be
founded on a commercial opportunity
which makes it hard to know just how
real it is what we do know is that their
unlikely union has given us an
entertaining window into a rarely seen
side of two of league's biggest names
it's also shown us that there's more to
the stars we watch on twitch every day
than their rage clips and highlight
reels they're real people with real
emotions and real butts that can be
spammed i'm so sorry that was an
experience
but i'm glad i could do it with you
faker
i told you with this bike ride but i
wear
a headband underneath my helmet so my
[ __ ] for like my you can see the
little color a little just a little bit
not a lot you know but a little color
but my forehead is literally just
white
for this line you should totally like
green screen
like simple behind me
or something and like a little broken
heart